ايضا خلال مؤتمر صحفي عقده في مقر الامم
المتحده ان الدول الغربيه تدرك جيدا ان
خطه الرئيس الاوكراني
للسلام غير قابله للتنفيذ لكن هذه الدول
لا تزال تؤكد انها الاساس الوحيد
للمفاوضات ووصف لابروب الخطه بانها غير
واقعيه
وكل من يحكمه في بروكسل ولندن في كلمه
واحده يقولون بقوه انه لا يوجد اساس اخر
للسلام غير صيغه يمكن وصف مخطط بطرق
مختلفه لكن من الواضح انه غير ممكن على
الاطلاق وغير قابل للتنفيذ المخطط غير
واقعي والجميع يدرك ذلك لكن في الوقت نفسه
يقولون ان هذا هو الاساس الوحيد للمفاوضات
وبشكل عام يقولون ان هناك حاجه لهزيمه
الاتحاد الروسي في ساحه المعركه وهذا ما
نسمعه كحقائق لذلك نستخلص استنتاجاتنا انه
لا احد يرغب في اظهار فهم جدي لما يحدث
اتفاقيه الحبوب وصف لافروب مقترحات الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو حول حول
اعاده احياء صفقه الحبوب وصفها بانها غير
واقعيه
السبب الرئيسي وراء مغادرتنا الاتفاق هو
ان كل ما وعدون به تبين انه كذب لقد
اوضحنا للامين العام سبب عدم النجاح
مقترحاته نحن لا نرفضها ولكنها ببساطه غير
واقعيه ولا يمكن تنفيذها كما هي